SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
WE CONTINUE TO WELCOME THE
PUBLIC IN PERSON. MOST OF YOU
KNOW THE RULES HERE. WE ALLOW
SIX MINUTES OF TESTIMONY PER
SIDE. I WILL SAY, PLEASE DON'T
FEEL OBLIGATED TO USE IT ALL.
YOU CAN SAVE SOME FOR WEDNESDAY.
WEDNESDAY'S HEARING. WE HAVE SIX
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA. FOUR OF
THEM ARE ON OUR PROPOSED CONSENT
CALENDAR, WHICH WE WILL TAKE UP
WHEN WE ARE ABLE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. IN THE MEANTIME, WE WILL
FUNCTION AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. AND
THE FIRST BILL UP IS ITEM NUMBER
THREE. SENATE BILL 1203 1230.
SENATOR RUBIO STRENGTHENED
TOBACCO OVERSIGHT PROGRAMS.
PROCEED WHEN READY, SENATOR.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. CHAIR AND
THE MEMBERS THAT WILL BE JOINING
US HERE TODAY. I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT SB 1230, THE STOP AND
SEIZE ILLEGAL TOBACCO PRODUCTS
ACT. WE ALL KNOW THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH EFFECTS OF SMOKING
CIGARETS AND VAPING FLAVORED
TOBACCO PRODUCTS. CALIFORNIA HAS
MADE GREAT PROGRESS IN REDUCING
THE USE OF TOBACCO PRODUCTS,
INCLUDING ADOPTING THE MOST
RECENT BAN ON SELLING FLAVORED
TOBACCO PRODUCTS. BUT MORE WORK
NEEDS TO BE DONE TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR LAWS ARE BEING FOLLOWED
AND ENFORCED. AS A SCHOOL
TEACHER FOR MANY YEARS AND
WITNESSING FIRSTHAND THE USE OF
THOSE FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS,
IT IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE MOVE THIS MEASURE FORWARD. I
KNOW ALL TOO WELL THAT
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS CONTINUE TO
HAVE EASY ACCESS TO THESE
ADDICTIVE VAPES WITH FLAVORED
DESIGNS TO APPEAL TO OUR YOUTH.
SB 1230 WILL STRENGTHEN THE
ENFORCEMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S
ANTI-TOBACCO LAWS AND ENSURE
THAT FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS
ARE KEPT OFF STORE SHELVES AND
OUT OF THE HANDS OF OUR STUDENTS
. SB 1230 WILL AUTHORIZE
EMPLOYEES OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION TO SEIZE AND
DESTROY FLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS, DISCOVERING DURING
THEIR REGULAR INSPECTIONS OF
TOBACCO RETAIL WAREHOUSES. THE
DEPARTMENT ALREADY HAS THIS
AUTHORITY TO SEIZE AND DESTROY
TOBACCO PRODUCTS THAT FAIL TO
INCLUDE THE PROPER STATE TAX
STAMP. SO THIS BILL IS VERY
SIMPLE. IT'S A COST EFFECTIVE
WAY FOR DEPARTMENTS TO ALSO
REMOVE FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS
FROM THE MARKET. SB 1230 ALSO
INCLUDES A REASONABLE INCREASE
OF THE EXISTING CIVIL PENALTY
IMPOSED ON RETAILERS, WHO BREAK
THE LAW BY CONTINUING TO SELL
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS TO OUR
YOUTH, AND ALSO C  CONTINUE TO
SELL THESE TOBACCO PRODUCTS TO
CHILDREN UNDER 21. THE FINE
AMOUNT ALSO HASN'T CHANGED IN 20
YEARS, AND THIS MODEST INCREASE
GOES A LONG WAY TOWARDS KEEPING
STUDENTS AWAY FROM TOBACCO. THE
STOP AND SEIZE ILLEGAL TOBACCO
PRODUCTS ACT IS SPONSORED BY THE
COALITION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS, INCLUDING THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION AND
THE CAMPAIGN FOR TOBACCO FREE
KIDS, AND THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION. TODAY WITH ME, I
HAVE TWO WITNESSES, SABRINA, TO
A HIGH, A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT
AND VERY IMPRESSIVE LEADER AND
ENCOURAGING FELLOW STUDENTS TO
REDUCE TOBACCO USE, WHICH WE
THANK HER FOR. AND TIM GIVES ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
TOBACCO FREE KIDS, WHO WILL BE
ANSWERING ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR, THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US. PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS SABRINA
TOURE. I'M A SOPHOMORE AT
MODESTO HIGH SCHOOL IN MODESTO,
CALIFORNIA. I'M TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF SB 1230 ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY.
CANCER ACTION NETWORK, THE USE
OF E-CIGARETTE FLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS IS A RAMPANT ISSUE AT
MY HIGH SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOLS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THOUGH PROP
31 BANNED FLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS, THE BAN IS NOT BEING
SUFFICIENTLY ENFORCED. AS SEEN
IN SCHOOLS SUCH AS MINE STUDENTS
STILL USE E-CIGARETTES IN THE
BATHROOMS, LOCKER ROOMS, AND
OUTSIDE CLASSROOMS. THE ENTICING
FLAVORS OF THESE PRODUCTS ARE
WHAT GET TEENS HOOKED. GIRLS IN
MY PE CLASS GATHER IN THE CORNER
OF THE LOCKER ROOM, EAGER TO GET
A HIT OF BLUE RASPBERRY, GUAVA
ICE AND STRAWBERRY FLAVORED
E-CIGARETTES. SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE SCHOOL YEAR,
THIS GROUP HAS EXPANDED AS THE
ENTICING FLAVORS HAVE DRAWN IN
MORE AND MORE STUDENTS. THIS IS
JUST ONE GROUP OF GIRLS. DURING
ONE CLASS PERIOD AT ONE SCHOOL,
DUE TO HOW EASILY ACCESSIBLE
THESE PRODUCTS ARE. CAN YOU
IMAGINE HOW MANY GROUPS LIKE
THIS EXIST IN CALIFORNIA? BEHIND
A ROW OF CLASSROOMS, STUDENTS
PRACTICE THEIR GHOSTS AS THEY
INHALE THE FRUITY VAPOR AND
EXHALE IT IN A CIRCULAR SHAPE. A
GIRL IN MY ENGLISH CLASS CAN'T
EVEN GO THE FULL PERIOD WITHOUT
USING THE BATHROOM TO VAPE,
SACRIFICING CLASS TIME TO HIT
HER PUFF. I WORRY ABOUT MY PEERS
FUTURE, AS THEIR ADDICTION TO
E-CIGARETTES NOT ONLY
JEOPARDIZES THEIR HEALTH, BUT
ALSO UNDERMINES THEIR ABILITY TO
FULLY REACH THEIR ACADEMIC
POTENTIAL. THE SECRET SHOPPER
SURVEY, CONDUCTED IN DECEMBER
2023, FOUND THAT 35% OF STORES
IN MODESTO SELL ILLEGAL FLAVORED
TOBACCO PRODUCTS. FURTHERMORE,
OUT OF 141 STORES THAT SELL
TOBACCO PRODUCTS, 50 OF THEM
SELL ILLEGAL FLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS. YOUTH CANNOT BE SEEN
AS A TARGET FOR ECONOMIC GAIN,
ONLY FOR SOCIETY TO ACCRUE A
LIFETIME OF HEALTH RISKS AND
ADVERSE OUTCOMES. I IMPLORE YOU
TO HELP THE NEXT GENERATION.
PASSING THIS BILL IS A CLEAR WIN
FOR ALL. WE NEED TO STOP
EXPLOITING THE VULNERABILITY AND
SUSCEPTIBILITY OF THE YOUTH.
IT'S CRUCIAL TO PRIORITIZE
ENABLING OUR CHILDREN TO PURSUE
HAPPINESS AND SUCCESS, RATHER
THAN FOCUSING ON GETTING THEIR
NEXT HIT, A SWIFT AND DEFINITIVE
RESPONSE MUST BE MADE BECAUSE
OUR INACTION IS EMBOLDENING
TOBACCO RETAILERS. I URGE YOU
ALL TO PASS THIS BILL AND ALLOW
THE CDTFA TO SEIZE AND DESTROY
THESE ILLEGAL PRODUCTS, WHICH
WILL HELP END THE YOUTH TOBACCO
EPIDEMIC. THANK YOU. EXCELLENT
JOB. THANK YOU SIR. WELL, I
CAN'T COMPETE WITH THAT. SO ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
TOBACCO FREE KIDS, WE URGE AND I
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE, PLEASE
STEP UP. NAME, AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURE ONLY,
PLEASE, MR. CHAIR AND MEMBER
AUTUMN OGDEN SMITH WITH THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY, CANCER
ACTION NETWORK, CO-SPONSOR. ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. Kò SPRUCE WITH THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT, WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. NORA LYNN, WITH CHILDREN
NOW IN SUPPORT, THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR MEMBERS.
JESSICA MORAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT GOOD
AFTERNOON, SYLVIA SOLIS SHAW
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR COMING.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE HEARING ROOM? WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. FIRST, ANY LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES SEEING
NONE. ANY WITNESS WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE, PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
SEEING NONE, WILL TAKE BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE DAIS AND MY
COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS IF THEY
WISH TO MAKE ANY. THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER THREE. SENATE BILL 1230.
SENATOR RUBIO, PRESENTING THE
STRENGTHENED TOBACCO. OVERSIGHT
PROGRAMS AND SEIZE ILLEGAL
TOBACCO PRODUCTS ACT BILL. ANY
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS OR CONCERNS?
SENATOR GROVE OKAY, WELL, WHEN
WE HAVE A QUORUM, WE'LL GET TO
TAKE A MOTION AND VOTE. BUT
SENATOR, YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, THIS IS REALLY
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. AS I
STATED, I'VE WITNESSED FIRSTHAND
HOW HARD IT IS TO DETER KIDS
FROM SMOKING AS A TEACHER. AND
THE TECHNOLOGY IS GETTING BETTER
AND BETTER AND HARDER AND HARDER
FOR OUR PARENTS AND TEACHERS,
PRINCIPALS AND ADMINISTRATORS TO
DETECT IN SCHOOLS. AND SO I WANT
TO THANK MY SPEAKER, SABRINA,
FOR BEING SO ELOQUENT AND THANK
YOU FOR THIS ADVOCACY. WITH
THAT, I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
WE'LL TAKE A VOTE WHEN WE GET A
QUORUM. EXCELLENT JOB. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US. BOTH OF YOU. THE
NEXT ITEM UP IS ITEM NUMBER 1266
BY SENATOR LIMÓN. PRODUCT SAFETY
, BISPHENOL. IF I'M PRONOUNCING
THAT CORRECTLY, SENATOR RUBIO,
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING YOU ARE
GOING TO BE PRESENTING FOR
SENATOR LIMÓN. CORRECT. PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE FIRST WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND SENATOR
LIMÓN WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS. AS SB 1266 SEEKS TO
PROHIBIT A MANUFACTURER FROM
SELLING CHILDREN, FEEDING,
SEEKING OR TEETHING PRODUCTS
THAT CONTAIN ANY FORM OF
BISPHENOL, ALSO KNOWN AS AT A
DETECTABLE LEVEL OF 0.1 PARTS
PER BILLION BISPHENOLS, COMMONLY
REFERRED TO AS BPA OR PSE, IS A
CHEMICAL COMPOUND THAT IS USED
IN A VARIETY OF INDUSTRIAL AND
CONSUMER PRODUCTS, RANGING FROM
AUTOMOBILE PARTS TO FOOD
CONTAINERS. BPA IS CONSIDERED AN
ENDOCRINE DISRUPTOR, WHICH MEANS
IT CAN INTERFERE WITH THE
HORMONE SYSTEM IN THE BODY AND
HAS ADVERSE HEALTH EFFECTS IN
CHILDREN AND ADULTS. ALTHOUGH
MANUFACTURERS HAVE ELIMINATED
BPA FROM BABY BOTTLES AND SIPPY
CUP PRODUCTS, THEY HAVE SHIFTED
TO USE ALTERNATIVE CHEMICALS TO
REPLACE IT, SUCH AS EPS AND
BPFS, WHICH HAVE BEEN FOUND TO
BE EVEN MORE HARMFUL THAN BPAS.
IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT WHEN TOXIC
OR POTENTIALLY HARMFUL CHEMICALS
ARE PHASED OUT OF PRODUCTS, THEY
ARE NOT SIMPLY REPLACED BY
ANOTHER HARMFUL TYPE OF
CHEMICALS. SB 1266 STRENGTHENS
THE COMMITMENT TO PROTECT
CHILDREN FROM HARMFUL CHEMICALS
AND AUTHORIZES HT, SC TO
ESTABLISH STANDARDS,
PRIORITIZING THE HEALTH AND
WELLNESS OF OUR CHILDREN. I HAVE
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT KAYLA
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF THE BCP
AND RYAN SPENCER ON BEHALF OF
ACOG. ARE YOU READY? PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
KAYLA ROBINSON, ON BEHALF OF
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS, BCP IS A SCIENCE BASED
ORGANIZATION WORKING TO PREVENT
BREAST CANCER BY REDUCING OUR
EXPOSURE TO CHEMICALS LINKED TO
THE DISEASE. BISPHENOL A, OR
BPA, HAS LONG BEEN A CHEMICAL
THAT BCP IS DEEPLY CONCERNED
ABOUT, GIVEN ITS ABILITY TO
DISRUPT OUR HORMONES, AND IT'S
LINKED TO BREAST CANCER AND
NUMEROUS OTHER HEALTH HARMS. AS
THE SENATOR MENTIONED, BCP
WORKED WITH ITS ALLIES TO REMOVE
BPA FROM BABY BOTTLES AND SIPPY
CUPS MANY YEARS AGO, AND TODAY
YOU WILL SEE BPA FREE STICKERS
ON NUMEROUS PRODUCTS.
UNFORTUNATELY, ALL TOO OFTEN,
BPA WAS REPLACED WITH AN
ALPHABET SOUP OF BISPHENOL
SUBSTITUTES BPF, BPF AND SO ON.
WHILE THESE SUBSTITUTES ARE
OFTEN LESS WELL STUDIED, THE
MORE WE LEARN, THE BETTER WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE ENTIRE CLASS
HAS IMPLICATIONS FOR OUR HEALTH,
INCLUDING INCREASED RISK OF
ASTHMA AND HYPERACTIVITY IN
CHILDREN AND CARDIOVASCULAR
DISEASE, FERTILITY PROBLEMS,
OBESITY, DIABETES, AND INCREASED
RISK OF BREAST CANCER AND OTHER
CANCERS AND ADULTS. EARLY LIFE
EXPOSURES ARE PARTICULARLY
CONCERNING BECAUSE THIS
DEVELOPMENTAL PERIOD IS WHEN
THESE CHEMICALS HAVE THEIR
BIGGEST AND LONGEST LASTING
IMPACTS, INCREASING OUR RISK OF
DISEASE, OFTEN DECADES LATER.
THIS EARLY LIFE IMPACT IS WHY SB
1266 BANNING THE FULL CLASS OF
BISPHENOLS IN CHILDREN'S SUCKING
, TEETHING AND FEEDING PRODUCTS
IS SO VERY IMPORTANT. AND THANK
YOU AND RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. RYAN SPENCER, ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OB-GYN DISTRICT NINE, IN SUPPORT
OF SB 1266, ACOG HAS LONG
EXPRESSED CONCERNS ABOUT THE
EFFECTS OF EXPOSURE TO
ENVIRONMENTAL CHEMICALS,
INCLUDING BISPHENOL A,
ESPECIALLY DURING PREGNANCY AND
LACTATION PERIOD. WHILE MUCH OF
A RECOMMENDATIONS ARE DIRECTED
TOWARD PREGNANT INDIVIDUALS,
IT'S CLEARLY IMPORTANT THAT ALL
PEOPLE, ESPECIALLY YOUNG
CHILDREN, SHOULD MINIMIZE THEIR
EXPOSURE TO THESE HARMFUL
CHEMICALS BY FURTHER REDUCING
CHILDREN'S EXPOSURE TO BISPHENOL
BY PLACING RESTRICTIONS ON THEIR
FEEDING OR TEETHING PRODUCTS. SB
1266 ALIGNS WITH ACOG'S MISSION
AND WILL CONTINUE TO PROTECT
CHILDREN. SORRY, CONTINUE TO
PROTECT CHILDREN AND INDIVIDUALS
FROM HARMFUL CHEMICALS, WHETHER
THEY ARE ABOUT TO GIVE BIRTH TO
A CHILD OR A CHILD THEMSELVES,
ASHLEY FRYBO. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU SIR. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE? SEEING
NONE, ANY WITNESSES AS OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE? SEEING NONE.
LET'S BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE DAIS, SENATOR, ANY
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS OR CONCERNS?
LOOKS LIKE YOU HIT A HOME RUN
TODAY, SENATOR RUBIO. SENATOR
MON, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? ON
BEHALF OF THE AUTHOR, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN,
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM AND WE
WERE ABLE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM,
WE WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION AND
VOTE ON THE MEASURE. THANK YOU
BOTH FOR JOINING US TODAY. AS
WE'RE WAITING FOR, MY COLLEAGUES
TO JOIN US IN THE HEARING ROOM,
AND I HOPE THEY'RE ON THEIR WAY.
I DID NOT REMIND ALL OF YOU,
WHICH BILLS ARE ON THE PROPOSED
CONSENT CALENDAR TODAY? AND ONE
IS ITEM NUMBER ONE, SENATE BILL
997 BY SENATOR PORTANTINO PUPIL
HEALTH. ITEM NUMBER TWO, SENATE
BILL 1099 BY SENATOR NGUYEN
NEWBORN SCREENING. ITEM NUMBER
FIVE. SENATE BILL 1382 BY
SENATOR GLAZER. COMMUNITY AND
RURAL HEALTH CLINICS AND ITEM
NUMBER SIX, SENATE BILL 1511,
WHICH IS A HEALTH OMNIBUS BILL.
AGAIN, WHEN WE ESTABLISH A
QUORUM, WE WILL TAKE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR UP AS WELL AS THE OTHER
TWO MEASURES WE JUST HEARD. HERE
WE SIT
.
WE'VE BEEN WAITING. WE'RE BACK
ON THE RECORD, YEAH. AND IT
APPEARS AS THOUGH WE MAY HAVE A
QUORUM. SO MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. SENATOR ROTH
HERE. ROTH HERE. WHEN YOU'RE.
WHEN HERE. GLAZER HI. HERE.
GLAZER. HERE. GONZALEZ GROVE.
GROVE. HERE. HURTADO LIMÓN.
MENGIBAR HERE. MENGIBAR. HERE.
RUBIO. SMALLWOOD RUBIO. PRESENT
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. HERE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. HERE WIENER.
WE HAVE A QUORUM. LET'S START
WITH THE PROPOSED CONSENT
CALENDAR. ITEM NUMBER ONE,
SENATE BILL 997. SENATOR
PORTANTINO, NUMBER TWO, SENATE
BILL 1099. SENATOR NGUYEN
NEWBORN SCREENING. ITEM NUMBER
FIVE. SENATE BILL 1382. SENATOR
GLAZER, COMMUNITY AND RURAL
HEALTH CLINICS, AND ITEM NUMBER
SIX, SENATE BILL 1511, WHICH IS
THE HEALTH OMNIBUS BILL. IS
THERE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR? SO MOVED MOVED BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATOR ROTH. AYE.
ROTH I WHEN I WHEN I GLAZER.
GLAZER I GONZALEZ GROVE CONSENT
IS WHAT WE'RE ON. YES. CONSENT
GROVE I HURTADO LIMÓN MENGIBAR I
MENGIBAR I RUBIO I RUBIO I
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS I WIENER. YES. SEVEN. YEP
I SHOULD HAVE MENTIONED THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AND THE VOTE IS 7 TO 0. WE'LL
HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. NEXT. LET'S TAKE UP.
ITEM NUMBER THREE, SENATE BILL
1230 BY SENATOR RUBIO
STRENGTHENED TOBACCO OVERSIGHT
PROGRAMS. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR GLAZER. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AND THE MOTION Þ. AND THE
MOTION IS TO DO PASS AND REFER
TO COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR ROTH I. ROTH I WHEN
GLAZER GLAZER I GONZALEZ GROVE.
HURTADO LIMÓN MENGIBAR I
MENGIBAR I RUBIO I RUBIO I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I WIENER. THE VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO WILL HOLD A ROLL OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT ITEM
ITEM NUMBER SENATE BILL 1266 BY
SENATOR LIMÓN. PRODUCT SAFETY.
BISPHENOL MOTION IS Dð PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. IS
THERE A MOTION? I'LL MAKE A
MOTION. WAS THAT RUBIO, SENATOR
RUBIO? RUBIO OKAY. YES, YOU CAN
DO THAT. YOU PRESENTED, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR ROTH.
AYE. ROTH AYE. WHEN I, WHEN I
GLAZER. GLAZER I GONZALEZ GROVE.
GROVE I HURTADO LIMÓN MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR I RUBIO I RUBIO I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I WIENER SEVEN. VOTE IS
SEVEN ZERO. WE'LL HOLD THE ROLL
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS 500 TO
GO. WE WILL AWAIT EIGHT
ADDITIONAL COLLEAGUES BEFORE WE
CLOSE THE ROLL
.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH
WILL BE IN RECESS FOR 15
MINUTES.
4:21 P.M. THIS AFTERNOON, WE'RE
GOING TO OPEN THE ROLL ON
MEASURES. WE'RE GOING TO START
FIRST WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE HAVE FOUR ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR TODAY. ITEM
NUMBER ONE, SENATE BILL 997 BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO PUPIL HEALTH.
ITEM NUMBER TWO, SENATE BILL
1099 BY SENATOR NGUYEN. A
NEWBORN SCREENING ITEM FIVE.
SENATE BILL 1382 BY SENATOR
GLAZER. COMMUNITY AND RURAL
HEALTH CLINICS, AND ITEM NUMBER
SIX. SENATE BILL 1511, WHICH IS
OUR SENATE OMNIBUS BILL. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS 7 TO 0. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
. SENATOR GONZALEZ I, GONZALEZ I
HURTADO LIMÓN WIENER I WIENER I
CURRENT VOTE 9 TO 0 WILL HOLD
THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
. NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
THREE. SENATE BILL 1230 BY
SENATOR RUBIO STRENGTHENED
TOBACCO OVERSIGHT PROGRAMS. THE
MOTION TO PASS WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO 0. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL. SENATOR NGUYEN. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO
LIMÓN WIENER Ã WIENER. Ã.
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO WILL
HOLD A ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. NEXT ITEM. ITEM NUMBER
FOUR. SENATE BILL 1266 BY
SENATOR LIMON. PRODUCT SAFETY.
BISPHENOL A MOTION TO PASS, AS
AMENDED. WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS AS
CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO.
CHAIR VOTING AYE. PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE. SENATOR GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HURTADO LIMÓN WIENER
WIENER I. CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO
WILL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU
.
OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO RESUME AND
PICK UP WITH THE BILLS. WE'RE
GOING TO START FIRST WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. AND WE HAVE
FOUR MEASURES ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ITEM NUMBER ONE,
SENATE BILL 997, SENATOR
PORTANTINO PUPIL HEALTH, ITEM
NUMBER TWO, SENATE BILL 1099 BY
SENATOR NGUYEN NEWBORN SCREENING
ITEM NUMBER FIVE. SENATE BILL
1382 BY SENATOR GLAZER.
COMMUNITY AND RURAL HEALTH
CLINICS, AND ITEM NUMBER SIX.
SENATE BILL 1511, THE HEALTH
OMNIBUS BILL. LET'S OPEN THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 9 TO 0.
CHAIR VOTING AYE. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
HURTADO HURTADO. AYE. LIMÓN AYE.
LIMÓN. AYE. VOTE IS 11 ZERO AND
THAT MATTER IS OUT. NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER THREE. SENATE BILL
1230 BY SENATOR RUBIO
STRENGTHENED TOBACCO OVERSIGHT
PROGRAMS. CURRENT VOTE IS 7 TO
0. THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND WE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR,
WHEN SENATOR GROVE HURTADO.
HURTADO. AYE. LIMÓN LIMÓN. AYE
VOTE IS NINE ZERO. THAT MATTER
IS OUT. FINAL ITEM, ITEM NUMBER
FOUR 1266. SENATOR LIMON PRODUCT
SAFETY. BISPHENOL CURRENT VOTE
IS 9 TO 0 AND THE MOTION DO PASS
IS AMENDED AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
HURTADO HURTADO. AYE. LIMÓN
LIMÓN. AYE. VOTE IS 11 ZERO.
THAT MATTER IS OUT. AND THIS
CONCLUDES THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON HEALTH FOR TODAY. HEALTH
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED